there was a very meaningful moment in my
career when I was in Park City Utah on a
snowboard trip with shelene Johnson
Brett Johnson I was with Louis how from
the school of greatness and I remember
Brett Johnson started to call me YouTube
he'd say hey YouTube we're going to
lunch hey YouTube come in here as he
started to say that I realized okay this
positioning thing actually has some legs
to it you want to be a meaningful
specific in a world of wandering
generality as the author of YouTube
secrets and at think media as we teach
about video overall but obviously lean a
lot into YouTube but being known for
YouTube Sean canell rhymes with YouTube
channel is a powerful position to
hopefully own the question for you is
what position do you want to own